[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE: I'm so excited to have
Mike Steib, CEO of XO Group--
The Bump, The Knot, The
Nest, you know them all--
here with us today.
Mike is an awesome guy.
But he's especially an
awesome guy in my life.
So I'm just going to open with
a little brief story of how
I came to know Mike.
It was the beginning
of my Google career.
This was like a long time
ago, like 9 and 1/2 years ago.
I was here.
I was in my job.
I was sort of like--
I was satisfied, but wasn't
feeling the love totally.
And this new guy had
moved onto the floor.
I'd seen him speak
at sort of an event
and noticed that he put this
little piece of notebook paper
on his glass door of his
office which, of course,
he shared with a
bunch of other people.
It would say Google
TV ads, now hiring.
And I was like, that
sounds interesting.
I think I should find out more.
And so I introduced
myself to Mike,
who would come on board
to run Google TV ads.
And my whole life and
career took a dramatic turn.
I did a 20% project, then I
joined the Google TV ads team
and so on from there.
In Mike I found an amazing
leader and mentor and someone
that I and lots
of us at the time
kept going to for career advice.
So I think he probably got
sick of having one-on-ones
with all of us.
And he actually
wrote this doc, which
maybe many of you in
this room are aware of,
called the Career Manifesto.
And it was literally
just a simple Google doc,
which took a lot of the advice
that he had been dispensing
about how to think about
career and just sort of put it
into writing.
Well, the Career
Manifesto went viral.
It got passed around beyond
the Google TV ads team,
beyond the walls of
Google, and has really
inspired a lot of people.
And now there is a rumor that I
cannot confirm that this Career
Manifesto may be
turned into a book.
And there is another rumor,
which I cannot also confirm,
that if you are here today and
you badge out and find Leah,
who's sitting in the back
and make sure to badge out
on the way out, you may or
may not receive a copy of this
book, which may or may not be
published later on this year.
But Mike is here to
bring it all to life.
Again, Mike, thank you
so much for being here.
It's so awesome to have
you back at Google.
And we're psyched to just
hear what you have to say.
MIKE STEIB: Thank you, Jesse.
I'm thrilled to be back.
You guys hear me OK
in the back there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MIKE STEIB: For anyone
who's watching the video,
I'm told this room seats 900.
It's almost full.
So this is really--
this is great.
So quickly, I'm not
licensed to do this.
First, it's probably
a disclaimer,
but Kate and Jesse
invited me to come
speak at an off-site here four
or five or six months ago.
And I've heard from
a number of folks
since who wanted to connect.
And so we came back.
I'm excited to do it.
I'm going to walk you through
essentially today a roadmap
for thinking about
your life, making
a plan for your life, which
I can't emphasize enough,
I'm completely
unqualified to do.
At the same time, I
have found it useful,
people who are important
to me have found it useful,
and you might as well.
We've got 60 minutes.
I have more.
So as folks-- if
you have to leave,
leave any time, of course, and
I'll stay after a little while.
I invite questions throughout.
And we're going to save time
for questions at the end.
Sound good?
Good plan for today?
All right.
First, I need two
volunteers to help.
Just-- it's wonderful.
You didn't even know what
I was going to ask for.
It could be anything.
Just tell me why you
came, what you were
hoping to get out of today.
AUDIENCE: So I know Jesse, and
I like to listen to her advice.
And I know it's always good
to get an outside perspective.
MIKE STEIB: All right.
Outside perspective and advice.
Anyone else?
Tell me just your
goal for today.
I want to make
sure we achieve it.
Anyone else.
What would you like
to get out of today?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE STEIB: OK.
So talking about
the cloud was not
in the original scope
of the presentation,
but I'm here for you guys.
So outside advice and
perspective and talk about
cloud.
Well, so all right.
That's what we're going to do.
Thank you, Kate.
Thank you, Jesse,
for the invitation.
Thank you Alan and Matthew
for getting this all set up.
What I want to do first
is a quick exercise.
I'm going to ask you
to close your eyes.
to admit something.
So Matthew, I would like
you to put your hand
in front of the camera.
You cover the camera.
I want you to raise
your hand if you
are living the life
and career that you
dreamed you would be living.
If you are on your dream
life's path, raise your hand.
OK.
Good.
Both of you, put
your hands down.
I've been there.
I know exactly--
I know exactly how you feel.
All right.
One more thing-- raise your hand
if you are engaged or married
and of childbearing years.
Raise your hand.
All right.
Download The Knot and The Bump.
That's what I do for--
that's what I do for a living,
and I would appreciate that.
So there's a website that
I want to tell you about,
and I'll footnote this
with a friend of mine
calls this discussion my
self-important obsession
with my own mortality.
But I want you to play along.
There's a website
called deathclock.com.
If you put some information
into deathclock.com--
do you take care of yourself?
Do you smoke?
When you're born?
It'll tell you, give or take,
when you're going to die.
So it doesn't know, but it's
from an actuarial table.
It gives you a bet.
Might be right,
it might be wrong.
Mine's May 2068.
All right.
So we've got a deadline.
And we've got-- now, I work out.
I avoid Third World
Airlines, but still there's
a limited amount of time.
You have a limited
amount of time.
And you and I, we sit in this
incredibly privileged position
in the context of the
history of the world.
The vast majority of human
beings who have ever lived
have lived very
short British lives
and have spent most
of their energy trying
to have food, shelter,
and to defend themselves.
Right?
Like, that was most
people's obsessions.
I have a friend who--
most of us in this
room, our grandparents
worked to make sure
no one starved.
That was the purpose of work.
And then I get to be
in a room with folks
like this who all were the
smartest kids in their classes,
went to good colleges,
work at Google.
Someone made a
movie about what it
takes to try to get a job
at Google, and you have one.
We're so fortunate.
Our lives are such a gift.
And yet many of us,
especially those
who come to obscure tech talks
about planning your life,
feel this dissatisfaction.
We feel this thing,
something is not quite right.
We all have this sense that we
have a limited amount of time,
and we have this sense that
we're blessed with something,
a really precious amount
of time and a really
precious opportunity.
And we're constantly
wondering if we're
doing the right thing with it.
Also people like us
have so many options.
So many options.
Headhunters call you guys?
They probably call you a lot.
And you're being recruited
by other companies.
You can really do anything.
If you work here, you
could do anything.
And there was a study done once.
Some weird psychologists had
people walk into a store,
and there were four
jellies on the shelf.
And they calculated how
many jellies they bought.
And then people would
walk in the store
and they put like 70
jellies on the shelf,
and they calculate how
many jellies people bought.
And the more jelly on the
shelf, the fewer people bought.
We're paralyzed by the array
of choices that we have.
So I'm going to walk you
through a little bit about how
I've thought about those choices
and some other folks have
found those choices--
and a way that other
folks have found
is a useful way to think
about those choices.
So I've got to skip some slides.
I've got to go back
to the beginning.
Any presentation that starts
with the definition of a word
is the worst presentation.
But I'm sorry.
I did this last night for you.
What's important?
Now, that word, there
are multiple definitions.
I picked one.
One definition is
of high status.
I like this one--
of great significance
or value, likely to have
a profound effect on success,
survival, or well-being.
Important.
And when you put
that in context, I'd
ask you a question--
how important are you?
Now, you could say, well, we're
all a unique and beautiful
snowflake.
We're all really important.
That's fair.
But like Mark Zuckerberg
is more important than me.
I'm willing to admit that.
It's very big of me.
How important are you?
There's an exercise
that I've done
and that others have
found helpful that I'm
going to walk you through now.
It answers, in a
way, this question.
So I'll start with you.
How important are you?
This is you.
And now think about the
impact that your life has.
An honest assessment of the
I first did this--
I was like 26 years old, and I
had this very prestigious job
at a big media company, where I
worked in corporate development
and strategy.
And we met with
important people.
I was very big in my britches.
And a friend of mine was
a kindergarten teacher,
and she asked me to speak at
the kindergarten for employment
day-- for jobs day.
And a little girl, she
was a kindergartner
or a first grader,
came up and said
to me-- they had these prepared
questions they had to ask you.
And the first one she said, do
you bring your lunch to work?
And I was like, no,
that's a good idea.
I spend a lot of money on lunch.
I should bring my lunch to work.
Thank you.
And the second thing she
said, she said, do you
work in New York City?
I said I do.
I work at Rockefeller Plaza.
It's really great.
Thank you for your questions.
Third question, she said,
is your job important?
I said, well, capital
allocation is an important lever
of the success of
a corporate entity,
and I guess this strategy
stuff, sometimes it's obvious.
But you know, someone
has to do these jobs.
And I make a lot of charts.
And this little girl is looking
at me, and then she said,
I'm supposed to write yes or no.
And I said no.
And I had an existential
crisis from a kindergartner.
And I went home, and
I did this thing.
So I was like, am I important?
What do I do?
Well, there's me and then what
things do I touch in the world?
It was my family and friends.
And those of you who know me
know I have like six friends.
So there's that.
I call my parents.
But I mean, this is not--
OK, fine.
That's nice.
When I describe my work, my
value of a replacement player
just wasn't that high.
And the impact that I felt
that I was having on the world
wasn't that inspiring.
I did a little bit of community
service stuff but nothing
where if you took me out
of the equation something
bad happened to the world.
I did the math, and I
was like, jeez, no wonder
that little kid
made me feel so bad.
I'm not having a
big enough impact
on the world with
what I would argue is
a pretty precious opportunity.
So that's depressing.
Like I said, but this is unfair.
So that exercise isn't fair,
because you're 26, you're 36,
you've got a lot of years to go.
And maybe you're
on the right path,
and you're going to have a
huge impact, just haven't yet.
So I did the exercise again
and said-- oh, and I called it,
this is the impact map.
I named this for you.
OK?
So the next thing,
it's like all right,
imagine I become much
more senior in my role.
I get my boss's boss's
boss's job, then
how much impact can I have?
And I sort of went through it.
And look, these are
personal judgments.
There is no right answer here.
It's what you
think is impactful.
I worked at a
company whose primary
KPI was the number of hours
people spent on their butt
watching television.
So I was like, even if
I get to be a lot more
important to this
company, I don't
know that I'm necessarily
having the impact that I
want to have on the world.
So I drew my map.
And I thought through
things that I could be doing
and if I was more
senior, if I had
more money, if I had more time.
But I sort of scoped
it out, and I started
coming to this conclusion.
I was like, I don't know
that I like the next 15
years that are laid out for me.
All right.
So this sucks.
I did it again.
I did a total zero
base of my life.
I was like, you're
a smart young guy.
You've got plenty of
time ahead of you.
If you can do
anything, and presume
for this second you
could do anything,
how much impact could I have?
And then this was
a hard exercise.
I literally at one point--
this is a true story--
I literally called
NASA and asked what you
have to do to be an astronaut.
And at the time I was thinking
space is so important,
but there's nobody out
in front like really
pushing new frontiers of space.
You have to be a pilot.
FYI, if any of you-- if
this was on your list.
And you sort of run the math.
You're like, all
right, I could do that,
but that might not
be the shortest
distance between two points.
This part of the exercise
will reveal to you, I think,
whether or not you're
currently executing
a plan that is going
to get you to a place
where you can have a big
impact with your life.
So there's you and
what you're achieving--
what I was achieving then--
what you might consider
you're achieving today.
Because you're a little bit
more senior, 10 years from now,
running the same
playbook, and then there's
blank space, whatever
you could do.
Anything.
Now, here I'll pause to
say, on this third exercise,
you have to suspend disbelief.
There's this thing
that nags at all of us.
We're like, well,
I know I'm smart.
I know I did well in school.
But I don't know that I
could fill in the blank--
found a company, run a big
company, run for office,
write a book, whatever
your thing is.
I don't know.
There are people who do that.
I'm not that person.
And I've had the pleasure
of meeting all those people
on the other side of it.
They're no smarter than you.
They don't know anything
that you don't know.
There are two
categories of people
who have a job that
you can't have,
like super superstar musicians
and super superstar athletes.
It's just like, I just am not--
I'm not big enough to be a
linebacker for the Giants.
So that one's out.
But if my life's
dream was to work
in baseball operations
for the Yankees
at a very senior level, of
course, I or you or any of us
could have that job.
If my life's dream was
to run a nonprofit that
has an impact on the developing
world, of course any of us
could have that job.
So you have to
suspend your disbelief
and think about what
you could be doing.
And you need to ask yourself
which one you like best.
This exercise doesn't presuppose
that the purpose of your life
is to maximize your impact.
The purpose of this
exercise is to think
about what it could be and then
ask yourself what you like.
Someone who worked for
me many years ago said
to me in a review, you
know Mike, I just--
I don't live to work.
I work to live.
I said that's fair, you're
allowed to say that.
You're allowed to
choose the first chart.
There are no judgments here.
But you should know
which one you want.
Don't say, well, I don't
really want all that
when you really do, because
you're afraid to try.
So that's exercise number one.
Completely unhelpful.
All this does is force
an existential crisis.
So hopefully-- some people
are nodding their heads.
Hopefully I've caused a
couple few existential crises.
Then the second
part of the exercise
is where you start
to define, well,
so what should I do about that?
Mike, the last
thing you said is I
could be anything
from an astronaut
to an entrepreneur
to a politician.
So which one?
And we think about
designing a product.
And the way that you
design a product is you
have certain things that
the product has to do
and certain things that
you would like it to do.
And you work really hard to
maximize all the things you'd
like it to do and not
sacrifice any of the things
that it has to do.
If we were designing
an iPod, it's too late.
But if you were
designing an iPod,
you'd say it has to play
at least 1,000 songs.
It has to last at
least 12 hours.
It has to fit in your pocket.
Everything else is a bonus.
And you'd start trying
to make the best product
within those constraints.
So now we've sort
of opened up the--
we've opened up the lens here.
We've zero-based how we
think about our life.
Now we start to say, OK,
well, if I can do anything
to have a big impact,
what do I want to do?
And here I did a
very simple exercise.
Make a list of things
that you love to do,
things that you hate to do,
and things that you cannot live
without.
So on the last
chart, I very well
may have concluded that the most
impactful thing I could do--
I once studied the
impact that you
can have through
nonprofits, and one
of the highest ROI,
the highest ROI
you can get nonprofit
work at the time I
did the research is distributing
mosquito nets in the developing
world.
The impact that it can have
on malaria and human health,
and it's significant.
That doesn't mean
that I necessarily
have to make that my job next,
because if you make this list,
like, I really hate travel
and hot places and mosquitoes.
So that one just might not
be the right one for me.
There was other stuff
on the list that
can be really impactful that I
can do that I also can really
enjoy.
So what do you hate doing?
And these things change at
different parts of your life.
I have two young kids, and
there are jobs out there
that are just 220 days a year
on an airplane or a hotel.
I won't do it.
That's a design
constraint on my life.
Travel some during the quarter,
but I can't live on the road.
I'll miss what's
going on at home.
It's a personal choice.
You fill this whole thing in.
And you have to do
it really honestly.
You have to be
honest with yourself.
And I'll use one example
where we never are.
And again, another really
personal question but it's
money.
How much money do
you need to be happy?
Well, we've all been trained
to answer that question.
We've been trained by like
Shel Silverstein poems
that what you're supposed to
say is money doesn't matter.
Money cannot buy happiness.
I don't care about money.
All right.
You ever live in a sixth floor
studio walk up with two kids?
It's hard.
There are trade-offs,
and there are
considerations that we have to
make in all of these things.
So take this one--
let's use this example, how
much money does someone need?
Because you get
tricked on both ends.
What happens is, there
will be a day, a moment,
where you have an opportunity
to choose among jobs.
They may be within
your company or they
may be outside of your company.
And here's how
they always look--
there's a thing that you
know you want to be doing,
and it's really cool.
It doesn't pay as much, but
you can live-- it's fine,
you can live on it.
And there's this other
thing, and then they
keep raising the
temperature and offering
you more and more and more money
not to do the thing you really
want to do.
It's a real choice.
Everyone does the same thing.
Everyone takes the money.
But we never ever
say-- no one ever
says I'm going to sacrifice
my dream to take the money.
Our brains are too good
at self-justification.
We never ever do that.
What we say is, I'll
take the money now,
and then in two or three years,
I can do anything I want.
Here's what happens-- whatever
money you make, you spend.
Trust me.
Whatever money you
make, you spend.
So if someone says
to you, hey, come
take a job that is inconsistent
with the impact you
want to have.
It's inconsistent with
the things you enjoy,
but we'll pay you
a ton of money.
What will happen is
you will spend it.
And then you will
not only be unhappy,
you'll have even less
flexibility in your life,
because now you have a house
in Montauk, which is great.
You used to have a
job you like, and you
rented a place in Quogue.
Now you have a job you hate,
and you own a house in Montauk,
and you have to keep the job.
These personal sort of
design constraints and design
considerations you have to
really fight with yourself
and wrestle with each
and every one of them.
And then you start
to come to a picture.
You've started to outline some
things that could be impactful
that you'd really love to do.
You start to outline
things that you would enjoy
and things you would not enjoy.
And you start to get
a sense for something
like what you'd want to do.
At this stage of the
exercise, I could probably
say I love working
with great people
and leading great people.
I love working in a
technology-related sector.
And I love to have work
that impacts lots and lots
and lots of users
in a positive way.
That's vague.
Like you can't add an objective
to your resume based on that,
but I get closer.
Oh, and the last part
of that is, I take--
just to lay on this point--
look at the credit
card statements.
Look at how much money
we spend every month.
Add up how much private schools
cost and the mortgage, dat dat
dat, and that adds up
to this much money.
I'm like, OK, I've got
to make that much money.
And any amount of money
over that, forget it.
I literally don't care.
I am not going to chase more.
I just need to hit--
I need to hit a certain bid.
Because if I don't hit this
bid, the next best school
in our district after
the private school
has a metal detector.
So I'm going to be right--
I'm going to land
it right there.
All right.
So then we're
narrowing the field.
We're designing this
product that is your life.
So now I'm just going
to filter the results.
Geography, function,
industry, company size.
Where do I want to live?
There are essentially
two choices--
New York or someplace else--
for me.
It depends on what
is important for you.
But there was a
period of my life
where I didn't internalize this.
And someone would
call and say we've
got this awesome
job for you running
six countries in Europe.
And I am not the Europe guy.
You know me.
Like, I'm not
supposed to be there.
But you go through this
crazy like, oh, maybe I
should go to Europe.
And I can sell widgets
to French people
and things will be great.
And then think of the career
I could have because I can put
global experience on my resume.
When I leave New York to
go on vacation, I'm sad.
I can't wait to get home.
I love New York.
That's my design constraint.
I have friends who feel
that way about Chicago,
who feel that way
about California,
who will not mess with Texas.
That's up to you.
Other people do not
have this constraint.
It means you can do way more.
I have friends who will pick
up stakes and go any time.
You have to know
the answer for you.
And the job shouldn't
decide that.
You should decide that
and then filter the jobs
before they interrupt your day.
Next is what function
should you do?
And this is, you
know, a lot of us,
you sort of take a job
coming out of business school
or something, and
that's your function,
and then you're just in
it, just in the function.
You all work at a great company.
They just let you switch.
A lot of places it's harder.
There are basically three
functions in any company.
We make it so
difficult. We make it's
sound difficult. You can
either make the stuff
or you can sell the
stuff or you could
support the people who make
the stuff or sell the stuff.
Those are basically
the three jobs.
So which one are
you going to do?
Are you going to make it?
Are you going to sell it or
are you going to support?
And then, is that marketing?
Is that finance?
Is that legal?
You don't have to stay
in the function forever,
but it's really healthy once
you start to narrow the field
and say I enjoy blank.
I enjoy design.
I enjoyed sales.
And if you have a hard time
with it, it's hard to say.
It's especially hard to
say when you're in the job,
because whatever job you're
in kind of sucks today.
That's life.
Because the job you're in today
comes with email and meetings
and a form you have to fill
out and an angry customer.
It always looks better to
be in someone else's job.
So you ask yourself,
what are the things that
stir my animal spirits?
When am I most psyched at work?
Is it when you are
organizing the stuff?
There are people
who get endorphins
when they are in spreadsheets,
taking chaos, and turning
that chaos into order, giving
that order back to the team
and helping that
team to run better.
That feels good.
Have you ever seen the way
the sweaters are lined up
in my closet?
It is the closet
of a psychopath.
I love when the comp plan
matches the behaviors
you want for the team.
That is fun for me.
That is a thing that I
get endorphins from that.
Other people, they just see
that a Google spreadsheet has
been opened on their
computer, like, gah.
They don't want to do it.
Some people, the thought
of going on a sales call
and convincing someone
to take something
that you want to give them
makes them want to throw up.
Some of us walk out of a meeting
where we've influenced someone,
and we're completely
energized by it.
So what are those
things at work?
It's not do I love the job that
I currently have in finance?
Do I love the job I
currently have in sales?
No, like every day it sucks
in one way or another.
But what is the essence of
the thing that I love doing?
Leading, influencing others,
organizing the world,
et cetera, et cetera.
It helps to narrow
down the functions.
Then you can ask industry.
Some people have a
strong opinion of this.
You probably should pick.
It gets harder and harder
to switch over time.
You guys all picked
a pretty good one.
And I'd skip this.
You work in a good industry.
You could switch
to food services
if you have a
passion for it, but I
think you're on the right path.
And then last is sort of
company size and company stage.
And a mistake that
many people who
work at big successful
companies make
is that your lens for the
world starts to become
big successful companies.
When I worked at Google--
this was a while ago--
there were only three jobs.
It was Google,
Facebook, and whatever
was the other hot
company people were
talking about that's
going to become
the next Google or Facebook.
That's all we talked about.
There is this enormous range
of companies of different sizes
and different stages at
which one could work.
Now, the more
enlightened among us
thought that there
was Google, Facebook,
the place that could be the
next Google or Facebook,
and some startup that called.
And so there was a fourth.
In between are companies with a
market cap between $200 million
and $20 billion that
need really good people.
And I've had friends who
were like, what I really
want to do is just
run a big function.
I'm like, you work at a--
this one or another one--
a really big company
where someone might not give
you a really big function.
But there's another company
with 1,000 employees, 5,000
employees, the sun would
rise and set on someone
with your talents.
So this is an important
consideration.
And it's one that many
of us miss, because--
I don't know-- anyone
here ever think
about working at like Open
Table or Grubhub or TripAdvisor
or HomeAway.
These are companies with
market caps of like $1 billion,
$2 billion, $3 billion.
They're so small.
Like Google belches $3 billion.
So to go work at a company where
the whole thing is worth that,
it's like oh, god.
Those are really
cool companies that
deliver really
cool services that
could really use great people.
To be clear, I'm not
asking anybody here
to go take a job like that.
But I'm just saying there's
a range of company sizes.
And whatever
company you work at,
you tend not to
see the other ones.
You ever-- startup people
are their startup people.
Oh, my startup's
getting too big.
I need a new startup.
OK, as long as that's
not because where you sit
is where you stand, you just
have started to form this bias.
If you really love it, then
that's the right thing for you.
And then there's stage.
Continuing excellence is the
stage of many large companies.
That can be fun.
Turnaround can be a lot of fun.
Take somebody's broken
company and fix it.
Startup can be a lot of fun.
You change the
paper in the copier.
It's up to you.
You've got to decide
what you like doing.
I have friends in
the harvest business.
That one is no fun.
They're like, OK, the
investors think the business
will last five more years.
If we can make it last eight,
we'll make a lot of money.
But that's a job.
It's an honorable job.
It helps keep the
economy moving.
You've got to make
your own decisions.
So through that
exercise, you start
to narrow down what are the
things that could have impact?
How could I be
important to the world?
How important do I want to be?
What are the things that I
enjoy or don't enjoy or things
that I need to be happy?
And then as I'm picking among
career choices, which are
the ones that feel right to me?
And you start to
narrow the field.
So over time, I was able to
narrow the field down to I
really like tech.
I want a smaller company but
one that has an opportunity
to have real impact.
I want something that I
think we can really grow.
I want to be in a significant
leadership position.
Then you can wait
for your pitch,
and you know when to
swing, because you've
got a good sense for that
thing that you're looking for.
If you look at the careers of
people who've been successful
and people who haven't,
generally speaking,
the people who've
been successful
have known what they're looking
for and they have a plan.
And the people
who've done OK tend
to have a career path that has
a lot of variety or no variety.
They stay in one
job in one function
and just wait to be
elevated or they keep
changing to try new things.
But you don't see a plan.
And so the next
part I would suggest
is once you've got a sense
for what you want to do,
you then come to grips
with the brutal fact
that you are unqualified for
that thing that you want,
completely unqualified
to do it today.
But you have the
ability and the right
to expect to be in that
position in some period of time.
And then from here to there,
you have to make a plan.
The way you make a plan--
here's one way you can do it--
think of the job
that you really want.
If mine got really
specific, I'd say
I want to be a senior
executive, a C-level executive,
in the tech space with
consumer-facing products.
Let's say I picked that one.
There are bios of senior
executives in the tech space
available on every
one of those company's
Websites.
Read them.
What experiences did they have?
Meet with people
who have these jobs.
Ask them what do you have
to be good at in your job?
You'd be amazed at who's
willing to talk to you.
Then you say, OK, those
are experiences I need.
Those are things I
need to be good at.
How do I get it?
Some of them are easy.
You need to know
how to manage a P&L.
You need to know how to read
the numbers for the job I just
described.
My wife was a banker.
She gave me a book.
It was like this thick.
It was on accounting
and finance,
and I read this horrible book.
I'd rather eat that
book than read it again.
But then I knew.
You knew what to debit
and what to credit
and the difference
between EBIT and EBITDA
and all these things that
are so confusing to someone
who hasn't read the book.
I read the book.
You basically get it.
There are other things that
reading the book helps,
but you really have to do it.
Managing a large team.
Anyone who has a big job
like the one I described
manages a large team.
At the time that I did
this impact map exercise,
I managed a team of one intern.
His name was Felix.
I was not qualified
to manage managers
in a large team at
an organization.
Tell me about your
leadership experience.
Like, well, one time Felix
wasn't doing what he should,
and I said Felix, I really need
you to do something different.
But what you can do with any of
these capabilities is you can--
you break it down
into its atomic parts
and say, OK, what does
leading a large team entail?
Being able to hire good people.
OK.
Break that down further, because
if you don't have a team,
you're not allowed to hire.
Knowing how to recruit
and identify good talent.
OK.
Anyone here can
participate in that.
If you are an
individual contributor
on a team that hires
from time to time,
ask your manager if you can
help be a part of the interview
process.
Tell your manager I've just
read two books on the topic--
read the books--
I think I've developed some
expertise on interviewing.
Can I please
interview a candidate
and give you my notes on the
person and compare with you?
That would take you
very little bit of time.
Now you're becoming someone
who's developing expertise
in interviewing.
Next, you get a Felix, and
you manage that Felix well.
You might break
down other elements
of a leader's position.
Being a good communicator.
There are books on this, and
there are opportunities for you
to demonstrate this at work.
You practice these things.
The worst thing that
could ever happen
is you get the job
of your dreams,
and you just never
put in the effort
to become good at those things.
You swing and miss when
you finally get the chance.
So this career roadmap,
you break the job
that you'd like to have
ultimately in your life
down into the things that
you have to be good at
and the experience
that you need.
And you go and you get them.
You go develop
those experiences,
sometimes through books, through
mentoring, through practice,
through side hustle.
It's up to you.
How are we on time?
Do we have any time left?
I think we do.
But what I want to
do is, the next part
is a little different.
So I'm going to pause
there and take questions.
Who has a question?
Is this helpful?
Useful?
There's a question.
AUDIENCE: How often do you
find that people are just--
AUDIENCE: Can you please
use the microphone?
MIKE STEIB: It's OK.
I'll just repeat the question.
Can you please say it?
AUDIENCE: How often do you
find that people are just
always striving for the
grass always being greener
or seeing something better
than what they currently
have when it turns out they're
just looking for something
else different as opposed
to this specific thing?
MIKE STEIB: How often do you
find that someone is just
looking for the next thing and
the grass is always greener
rather than looking
for the right thing?
Always?
All the time.
It's a great question.
And it's why having
a purpose and a plan
is so important to your success.
And I want to, if I can, I
want to sort of break that
question down into two parts.
Because one is just
vague dissatisfaction
as a driver of a career
is not necessarily
going to get you
to the right place.
This is obvious, right?
But you don't know
where you're going.
The faster you run in that
direction, the more likely
you are to miss it.
The second component of that
question-- so have a plan.
So part of the answer
is if you have a plan,
and you're jamming
to achieve that plan,
you're on the right path.
Second part of the question is,
you might have asked it there.
I might ask.
Hey, I'm really ambitious
so I'm always miserable,
because other people
are more senior than me
or more successful.
Have you ever felt that?
Somebody ever like leave your
team or leave the company
and go somewhere else and get a
better job and a better title,
and you're like oh, that person?
Please.
The guy is terrible.
Like there's someplace
you want to be
and then other people seem to be
someplace else and you're not,
and it makes you
like, aah, crazy.
So that's not healthy either.
Not being ambitious
is not healthy.
Not having a plan
But then always being
miserable because you
want to be somewhere
else is not healthy too.
So as you think about it,
here's a good exercise to do.
Imagine the sum of all of
your dreams-- astronaut,
like whatever it is--
you want to be CEO
of pick a company.
You want to run such
and such, just pick it.
And if you wanted
a ton of money,
give yourself $100 million
bucks, put it all in a pile.
Put it on a pile on a plate.
And I will give it to you.
It's a trade that
you have to make.
I will trade you something.
I will give you all
the things you want,
and all you have to give me
back is the health of someone
important to you or your
sight or your limbs,
your relationship
with your parents.
Very few people would
make that trade, which
means you currently have--
this is mathematically
true-- you currently
have more value than all the
things to which you aspire.
What you have right now is
worth more than all the things
that you want.
So it would be criminal,
it would be horrible,
to have all of that and
be miserable all the time,
because somebody else got a
raise you didn't or a promotion
you didn't.
It would be awful to set
yourself off on this journey
to have impact, but
all along the way
to be miserable because you
haven't had the impact yet.
So the balance, the trick,
and it's hard to do,
is to enjoy today and be
driving for greater impact
that you want to
have in the future.
A great way to do that--
one man's opinion, take
it for what it's worth--
is just don't multitask.
If you're with your friends,
turn off your phone.
Yes, there's interesting
stuff going on on your phone,
but there's interesting stuff
going on with your friends too,
and if you're half on the phone
you missed the whole thing.
Yes, someone else got
promoted or something
is going on at work
that's stressing you out,
but be in the moment
that you're in now.
Don't be stressing out about
some stuff going on over there.
That's a balance.
And it's a balance.
It's a great question, though.
Thank you.
Other questions, in the back.
AUDIENCE: So as you're going
through these exercises
and identifying what
you need in order
to set up the filters to
build a plan, how do you
or what recommendations do you
have for someone that says,
I don't know?
And I don't know
what I would love.
MIKE STEIB: The question is, if
you're going through all this
and you don't know,
what should you do?
This is the tyranny
of choice, right?
This is what's so hard.
There was some experiment
where the psychologist gave--
they brought a group of
people in and said they could
have a free pair of jeans.
And they said to the
one group, they're
like just pick a pair of jeans.
They had three jeans.
It was tighty jeans and
regular jeans and baggy jeans.
And everyone under 30, I
guess took the tighty jeans.
They had another group
come in, and they
were like we have 60
different kinds of jeans.
They had every different
kind that you want,
and later they ask people how
happy they were with them.
And the people who had
fewer choices were happier.
The people who had more choices
had all this regret over
whether or not they
took the right ones.
So if your question is, you go
through this whole exercise,
and you're just
paralyzed by the choice--
paralyzed-- give
yourself a deadline,
and give yourself a method.
All right?
I did a thing where I woke
up every morning at 5:00 AM
and I would write.
I would write and
write and write.
I wrote bucket list.
I wrote a eulogy.
I wrote the book report that
I would want my granddaughter
to write about me some
50 years from now.
Write, write, write,
all these things
that I wanted to be true.
Mike Steib, what do you want
it to say in your eulogy?
Mike Steib leaves
us at 125 years old.
He still has all
of his hair, and he
has 90 wonderful
great-great-grandchildren.
Whatever your thing is, like
what are those things that
are important?
The more you go through that
exercise, the more clarity
it gives you.
And I can't emphasize
this enough-- writing
is really powerful.
Not typing, writing.
It just seems to touch a
different part of your brain.
And that exercise starts
to bring you clarity.
And then wander the earth.
Tell you yourself,
I'm going to go
talk to these 10 people
who have careers--
different kinds of careers--
that they seem to enjoy,
and I'm just going to ask
them how did you do it?
What was interesting?
What did you like?
Do that exercise.
If you still don't
know what to do,
that means you're indifferent.
Pick one.
Pick one and stick with
it, and just go for it.
Pick one that's like--
and honestly, there is no
perfect answer for you.
Unless you are Wolfgang
Amadeus Mozart,
you are supposed to play
piano, like 99.9999% of us
are not supposed to do anything.
So pick one.
I have a friend who's an
author, and I said to him--
this was a couple of years ago.
I was like this is so great.
You wrote a book,
like you're a writer.
How did you know
you were a writer,
and he was like that's the
stupidest question I've ever
heard.
You're a writer after
you write a book.
So you don't know you're a
writer until you write a book.
Then you're a writer.
I'm like, no, but
like a real writer.
He's like they
don't do that they.
Don't split them
into categories.
There's just a writer.
So if you can't pick--
I put my email up before.
Just email me.
I'll give you something.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
heard from a lot of people
is to never try to over-engineer
that things change,
that opportunities come
up, and that if you
are too busy planning, you
will miss opportunities.
MIKE STEIB: Oh,
that's interesting.
AUDIENCE: What's your
perspective on that?
MIKE STEIB: The question,
if you didn't hear it,
was I think the opposite of
everything you just said.
What was your name?
AUDIENCE: Matt.
MIKE STEIB: So Matt
said, I've gotten advice
that you shouldn't try to
over-engineer your career,
because you could
miss something.
It's very good advice.
But I might express
it differently.
You should be iterating
this plan regularly.
You should regularly be asking
yourself, what kind of impact
do I want to have?
What career roadmap
do I want to execute?
As you're in the field, as
you're doing and learning,
you should be
iterating that plan.
There is some moment when a
bunch of people who really
wanted to work in media defined
it as television and missed
internet.
Did not reboot their
career plan for maybe
I'll do something
in the internet,
much to later their dismay.
So I would say you
should have a plan
and you should engineer it, but
in the same way that we develop
products and put them
in front of our users,
launch early and
often, you should
learn from the
experience, and we
should iterate to the
next level of the product.
And I that gives you
the best of both.
It gives you a plan.
You're not just wandering
in the wilderness.
And it allows you to
take new data points
and incorporate
them into that plan.
That would be my
advice, but everybody's
got to do their own thing.
The Chairman of LinkedIn wrote
a book, which is very good,
and it is very popular.
And it basically
just says, hang out
with really smart
interesting people
and some good shit will happen.
And he has a lot
more money than me.
So you pick.
Like, there are different
ways to execute it.
My humble advice
would have a plan
and consistently edit
that plan and iterate
that plan as you learn more.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So some of
this comes out to,
and I think you were alluding
to it in the beginning is,
big fish, small pond.
Small fish, big pond.
And so what do you attribute
sort of general happiness to?
Is there a preference
to you as far as either?
And then do you think
there's a correlation
small-pond environment
allowing you to [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE STEIB: Elliot
asked, what's better?
To be a big fish in a small pond
or a small fish in a big pond?
And it is completely
dependent upon what you enjoy.
Big fish, small
pond is my job now.
My company has 800 employees.
I make a decision, and we do it.
I actually remember when
I first took the job,
I said to my CFO--
there was a company we wanted to
buy-- and I was like, OK like--
I was like who do we
have to talk to now?
And she was like, nobody.
You're the CEO, you just buy it.
I said whoa.
I guess this is what
I signed up for.
At the same time in the job--
a job I had had
previously, the only way
to get anything thing done
was to build coalitions
and get everybody on the same
page and manage stakeholders.
Some people are really
good at one of those.
Some people are
good at the other.
Some enjoy one.
Some enjoy the other.
For me, that's essentially
what determines bigger company
versus smaller company.
I'd also comment that
it's a false choice.
Because there are people--
this is a big company, right?
But there's a small group
working on the Google Space
Elevator or whatever
you guys are up to,
that I'm sure it doesn't feel
like a big company over there,
right?
There's probably like 10
engineers and a product
guy and a marketer, just
trying to launch it into space.
So it's not only company, it's
team, and it's [INAUDIBLE],
and it's how much that thing
is the same as everything
else going on at the company
or how much it's unique.
The more it's the same,
the more your skill set
has to be bureaucratic
in nature.
And the more it's different,
the more your skillset
has to be getting things
done in nature, I'd say.
Thank you, Elliot.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk more
about living below your means
and how this plays into the
decisions you're talking about?
You mentioned renting in Quogue
and now you own in Montauk.
Can you explain a
little bit more,
you now, like you live
frugally, like how
that impacts this stuff?
MIKE STEIB: The question
was, can you talk about--
it's a good question-- living
below your means and how that
can create optional--
I think that
creates optionality.
It gives you flexibility
in your career.
I have never
successfully done it.
And there are people
who go on CNBC,
and they'll tell you
the way to become
a millionaire is you just
stop having a latte every day
at Starbucks.
And then over time,
the interest compounds,
and you'll be a millionaire.
I've met millionaires.
No one has ever said to me, I
just stopped drinking lattes,
and now I'm loaded.
It's good to be a saver.
It's good to live
below your means.
People who do that are
better people than I am.
What I have found instead
is that whatever you make,
you spend.
And therefore, to
the earlier point,
I figure out what we really
need at this moment in time
in our family to be happy.
And then how much
we need to save
for retirement and the kids'
school and all that stuff.
You add it up, and that's the
amount of money I need to make.
And I'm painfully aware
that if we make any more,
we're just going to get an
extra bedroom on the apartment
or something.
In my life, it's just
going to get spent.
And I also know that that
extra bedroom in the apartment
is not happiness.
Living the career and the
life with a purpose that is
meaningful to me is happiness.
And I have friends
who have successfully
gone this way too--
they have just said,
look, we spend too much money.
It's not worth it.
Let's get down to
the basics of what we
need so that we can be happier.
And that's fair too.
I don't know that I could
successfully pull that off
either.
It just feels to me
like the spending
becomes somewhat permanent.
And so in a weird way, my advice
is know what that number is,
make it, disregard any
more that you make,
and understand that if you
do make it and you save it,
you're really a good person.
But if you spend it, I feel you.
I've been there.
I'll come right back to you.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit more about your roadmap
as it related to decisions you
made after being at Google?
So [INAUDIBLE]
after leaving here?
MIKE STEIB: So my
roadmap and the decisions
I made after leaving Google.
I had a terrific job and worked
with great people at Google.
My job over time became
more bureaucratic,
which wasn't for me.
And also there's
the point at which
you might feel in your career
this sort of flattening
of either what you're
learning or just is
sort of the trajectory
of your career
and the current
path that you're on.
And someone called me
with an opportunity
to be the CEO of
basically something that
was being built from scratch.
And it checked a
bunch of boxes for me.
And it was the
absolute wrong one.
It was a catastrophe.
Catastrophe.
But in doing it, I got to,
really for the first time
in the wild, be a CEO.
And I absolutely loved it.
And I learned a ton.
And it went well.
Operationally, it was working.
Our issue was sort of
investor-relations related.
But operationally,
it was working,
and I was like I think
I can do this job.
And the next thing
that presented itself
was even better.
And it's where I am now.
So in a way--
this is as a personal
anecdote, and I
don't know what it's
worth, but I made a mistake
when I made a change.
But the bigger mistake would
have been not making a change.
Optimally, I would
have left for something
that was a success and not
a catastrophe right out
of the gate and saved
two years of my life.
That would've been optimal.
But the next best option
was just forward progress.
I can't emphasize how
important doing is to success.
And it sounds so obvious.
But I have a story about
a friend of some of ours.
Remember when Yahoo
bought Tumblr?
I don't know why.
He was possessed with the Idea
Like he started blogging about
that this was a bad deal.
I was like, who cares?
But our friend really cared.
So he was blogging and
blogging about that
this was a bad deal for Yahoo.
And then he pinged
some people on Twitter.
He was like, what do you think
about all the things I've
been writing about
what a bad deal this?
And people tweeted
about it and so on.
And then Bloomberg
Television called him
and asked if he'd come on as an
expert to talk about this deal.
Everyone is looking
for someone who
knows what they're talking about
and knows what they're doing.
And no one does.
So if you just act like
you do, you eventually
get the shit you're after.
So forward motion,
it's really important.
And I don't know.
For whatever that's worth.
That's my life.
I wouldn't do it if
I were someone else.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So my question
was about if [INAUDIBLE]
and they think that's kind
of what you [INAUDIBLE]
to but sometimes-- and filter.
Maybe you say I
don't want to work
anywhere else than your are.
But then a really
good opportunity
presents itself somewhere else.
How do you think about
temporary sacrifices
that you can make to make
stronger [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE STEIB: The
question was, how do you
think about temporary sacrifices
in your design principles
to move your career
ahead more quickly?
It's really important to know
which of your design principles
are constraints versus desires.
So for me, a
constraint is the time
I need to spend
with my children.
There are jobs that for two
years I just won't to see them,
but it's only two
years, but they'll never
be this age again.
So for me, that one
I won't budge on.
I won't budge on it at all.
There's other stuff that--
most people are not as psycho
as I am about wanting
to live in New York.
They'll take it, but they'd
also move to California
for the right deal.
So you just have to
know which ones for you
are fixed constraints and
which ones are negotiable.
And fixed constraints,
don't even think about it.
Like you made a principle
decision with clear eyes,
and then something
came along and tried
to get you to think differently.
At one point in my career,
I just said, you know what?
I'm not going to play golf.
I'm just not.
Everyone keeps trying to
pressure me to play golf.
Oh, business gets done
on the golf course.
You have to play golf.
We're going on a golf trip.
No.
I hate golf.
I'm not doing it.
It's so liberating.
It's liberating.
Now, every time
someone's like, oh hey,
we're putting this
thing together.
There's golf.
I'm like, psht, nope.
I'm not doing it.
You've got to decide what those
fixed constraints are for you.
Other questions.
AUDIENCE: I love that
this approach is really
inward looking, but what
are some good questions
to ask mentors and advisors to
get the best advice from them?
MIKE STEIB: What are
the best questions
to ask of mentors
and advisors to get
the best advice for them?
There's a book called "The
Finer Points of Leadership."
That's good read, and
there's a concept in there
called The Career Covenant.
And The Career Covenant is
you agree with your manager,
that I'm going to do
really good work for you
and help make you as
my manager successful.
What I'd like from you is advice
and championing my career.
Would you be willing
to do that with me?
Any manager worth their
salt will say yes.
Then with a manager
like that, you've
negotiated that
we're going to be
talking about my career
from time to time.
And just ask anything.
I ask for feedback.
A great way to
ask for feedback--
everybody in this room, like
you go to the tech talks for--
like you're probably winning.
You're probably
getting good scores.
Your feedback is usually
you're doing a great job.
Say, if I was a
managing director,
what would I have done
differently with this project?
Well, I mean, you're
not a managing director.
I'm not asking you to make
me a managing director.
What's the difference between
me and a managing director?
Well, you would have asked
somebody a million questions.
That's fair.
That's helpful.
Tell me what I could
have done to not
ask so many annoying questions
and on and on and on.
So I think forcing
feedback on yourself
that is not just,
did I do a good job,
make me feel good about the
job I just did but, OK, people
are much better than me.
What would they have
done different gets
you the kind of feedback that
can really fuel your career?
And then I think with people
who you don't know as well,
people who are in other
jobs, other professions, when
you meet people, just be so
vulnerable and willing for them
to know that you don't know
what they're talking about
and keep, keep, keep
asking them questions.
So you're at some
like-- my wife makes
me go to these fancy
dinners, and you
have to meet random people.
This is terrible.
Days of my life.
And so you're like, hey,
what do you do, Tom?
And Tom's like, oh, I
work in debt capital
markets for Goldman Sachs.
But everyone says, they're like,
oh cool, debt capital markets.
How's debt capital
markets going this year?
I say, what's debt
capital markets?
Which is, it's
embarrassing, right?
How long have I
lived in New York?
How could I not know what
debt capital markets is?
Tell me.
I don't work in finance.
What's debt capital markets?
Oh, we create liquidities for
investment-grade companies.
What's liquidity?
For some reason, people
describe their jobs
in a way that makes it
sound so complicated.
And when you keep asking,
they finally give up.
And they say, we
loan money to GE.
What I say, I say,
oh, that's brilliant.
I say GE makes a lot of money.
Why would they need
to borrow money?
He says, honestly,
these days it's just
to buy back their stock.
It's financial engineering.
And then I go how
does that work?
And then they explain it to you.
And I'm like, what do you have
to do to be good at that job?
GE can borrow money from anyone.
They have great credit.
Why would they
borrow it from you?
He says, oh, it's all sales.
Tell me how you win in sales?
For me, it's a
relationship game.
I take the guys
out, ba ba ba ba,
and I know more
about the market.
How do you know more
about the market?
It is like-- anybody else
have a five-year-old?
I have a five-year-old.
I am the five-year-old of
asking you about your career.
Why?
Why did you do that?
What does that mean?
What's the opposite of apple?
Da da da da, like
on and on and on.
I just keep going until I really
know what this person does,
and I can really engage
them in a discussion,
I've taken something from
them or until they just
like they surrender.
And one way they surrender
is they go, what do you
do, to try to make you stop.
The other is they drink
their drink really fast,
and they're like,
oh, my drink's empty.
I have to go to the bar.
That's all right.
The people who stay
with you, these
are people that you're
now familiar with.
Next time you see them,
I'm not like, hey,
Tom from debt markets.
How are you?
I'm like, Tom, I just
heard interest rates moved,
and I remember what
you told me about what
that means for liquidity.
Are people still
buying back stock?
And he's like, you're
not going to believe it.
Nobody's buying back
stock or it's 10% to gold.
This year we're getting killed.
Like I'm having a
conversation with Tom.
So if you're talking to a
mentor or someone in an industry
that you like, just
ask questions like--
I don't know-- like
a five-year-old.
There's got to be a
better way to say that,
but ask questions
like a five-year-old.
We've got a couple minutes left.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: How do
you manage your time
when it comes to
[INAUDIBLE] aspect of career
[INAUDIBLE] versus [INAUDIBLE]
MIKE STEIB: The next
question was time management,
but people have a meeting next.
So I'll pause for a second.
Anybody needs to go, go.
And I'll stay and answer the
time management question,
even if you don't stay.
So we'll give it a minute.
Thank you guys for coming.
It was great to see you.
[APPLAUSE]
Next page is time management.
How much time have you got?
I'll give you like the
three-minute version.
And then if you
want to ask more,
but you guys are welcome to
leave as you want to leave.
So you're working hard,
and you have obligations.
You have family.
Some of you are in an
adult kickball league,
like there's just no time left.
Right?
So how do you also work a career
plan and meet with mentors
and read books on accounting
and all that stuff?
So you have to be
hyper productive.
And if you calculate
the number of hours
that are already spoken
for in your life--
you have sleep eight hours,
you have to sleep eight hours.
Don't believe anyone
that tells you otherwise.
You must sleep eight hours.
You have to exercise
an hour a day.
Have to.
You really should.
You have to bathe.
You have to.
Eat.
And if you're ambitious,
you work 60 hours a week,
which over seven
days averages out to,
call it 8 hours, 8
and 1/2 hours a day.
You add that all up, on an
average day, blending weekends
and weekdays, you have five
hours of discretionary time
every day.
You have five hours to live.
That's your time to
proactively decide
how you are going to spend
it and what you're going
to achieve with your life.
The average American
spends five hours a day
on social media and television.
And then they all
say, I have no time.
[CHIMES]
And the bell tolls for you.
If for five hours you
could be doing anything
you want, anything you want.
You could put more
hours into your work,
so you don't work 60
hours, you work 70.
There have been points in my
career where it's been 80.
You decide when
that's appropriate.
If you have kids, you
owe time to your kids.
I love my children.
Five hours every night's a lot.
A lot.
Two gets you there.
You have time with friends,
you spend it proactively.
You decide how you're going
invest those five hours.
A portion of those five hours,
I invest in personal development
almost every day.
Right?
Reading.
There's a list of things
that I know I want to read,
and I know I want to learn.
Spending time with
people in the space
who can give you
perspective, et cetera.
A proactive investment
of that time.
If you believe the
10,000-hour rule,
with five hours every day,
in just a few years you,
could also be a concert pianist.
This is up to you.
Five hours is a ton of time.
But most of us don't
invest it proactively.
It gets invested for us.
We work.
You get up, you're like,
shit, what am I doing today?
All right.
You scramble.
You're like, I'm not going
to go to the gym now.
I'll go after work.
You work.
Somebody bothers you,
and then it's 6:00
and you've got to get home, and
then you didn't go to the gym.
And you're home, and you
scramble with the kids,
and then you're just beat.
And you're like,
all right, I know
I have some work to do but I'll
just like veg out for a minute.
And next thing you know,
Netflix is saying to you,
are you still there?
Has that ever happened to you?
Get a life.
Of course I'm still here.
I have found that
when I proactively
say how I want to spend my time
and then put it in my calendar,
that it works.
And you calendar is this really
powerful operating system.
You never miss a one-on-one
with your manager,
because it's in your
calendar and you go.
And yet, somehow we keep
not going to the gym.
It's in my calendar.
When I read is in my calendar.
When I get in bed
is in my calendar.
It's really weird.
But it is really effective.
There's this block
of time on Saturday
that is my personal
time, not with my family,
and it's not work related.
It's investment in things
I want to learn, explore,
or contribute.
It's my time.
It's 5:00 AM to about 10:00 AM.
That's mine.
There's this block
of time where it's
going to be me with the kids,
and I will not check an email.
I cannot be bothered.
I'm going to be with my kids.
It's dedicated time.
And it's so much more powerful
when you wake up on Saturday,
and you're like all right,
what are we going to do?
So the most impassioned advice
I could give you on this topic
is to proactively
schedule your five hours.
I can also tell you, and
I said this in passing,
but when you sleep, you really
are much more productive.
They did an experiment.
People were asked to sleep six
hours a night for two weeks,
and they performed
cognitively and physically
at the same level of
people who had pulled
back-to-back all nighters.
When you don't sleep,
you suck at everything.
And we're all
ambitious, and so we're
looking for an extra
hour and an extra hour.
And you take it out of
sleep, and it's massively
destructive to your
ability to be productive.
So the way to do it--
I said before, like
I literally have
an alarm that goes
off that tells me
it's time to get in bed.
And I have to plug my
phone in, not by my bed,
because if I bring my
phone to the bed, then
I will lay in the bed with
the phone for another hour.
The phone is actually
over by the door
next to my gym clothes.
And when the alarm goes off,
I get up, I get out of bed,
I go, I grab the phone,
and I'm right there
with my gym clothes.
So I know I have to
go to the gym now.
You can create these
barriers or these guardrails
in your life that force you to
proactively and intelligently
invest your time
in the things that
maximize your productivity.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: What is [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE STEIB: Oh, so this was, if
we had enough time, essentially
quickly, the way to
manage your to-dos is
to figure out what's the goal
you're trying to achieve?
How much impact can
this action item have?
How fast can you do it?
And by when is it due?
And we have a tendency
to go to a meeting
and some to-dos come up, and
they go to the top of the list.
And my advice is, you will never
do everything on your list.
So always assess every to-do and
only do the high-leverage ones
that you can-- first the
ones you can do quickly
that are due soon and then
the high-leverage ones that
take a long time.
And match them to the amount
of time that you have.
So you know how you have
15 minutes between meetings
so you come back to your
desk and you open an email,
and it's like a 20-page
PowerPoint you're
supposed to read?
And then you read
like four pages of it,
but then the 15 minutes are up.
So then you run to the meeting,
and then you come back,
and you're like, OK,
let me go to my email.
And you're like,
oh, this PowerPoint.
Where was I?
And you basically start over.
Not matching the important
task to the amount of time
with which you can
use to get it done
is the way that most people
make themselves unproductive.
It was really nice
to see you guys.
This was a lot of fun.
This is how to get in
touch with me if you want.
I'm more than happy to help.
It's great to see you.
You're all friends or
friends of friends,
and I'm at your disposal if
I can ever be useful to you.
Thanks, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]